my name's brian newman i'm with renew
media and you probably don't know our
name because it was just a few months
ago that we were called national video
resources and we changed our name
recently to renew media and we were
norges it we are an organization founded
by the Rockefeller Foundation to help
filmmakers get their films funded and to
distribute them to as wide an audience
as possible how many of you in the
audience are filmmakers or producers or
somewhere else so Mike Rizzo case with a
few we're your best friend in a sense
because we have money and solutions for
getting your film out there and we were
not specifically set up in any way to
address open content however something
we've been thinking a lot about lately
and I recently went down to the Hewlett
conference at Rice University on open
educational resources and one of the
things i learned there and that I've
learned here not from these particular
speakers is that this movement has a
real need for learning storytelling and
needs to learn how to tell it's dreams
and its vision and its success stories
better to get more people interested in
this area and the area hi men in film
and video is the land of probably too
many stories not just in terms of
narratives and documentaries but also a
lot of false stories and a lot of false
stories of success and so I want to talk
about a little bit about some realities
in the video marketplace and then talk
about three intervent interventions that
we've done along this area in terms of
financing one of which at the end is
sufficiently heretical enough I think
for this audience that it should at
least get everyone's attention away from
the computers for a few moments how many
of you have heard of the film supersize
me by Morgan Spurlock so most I think
everyone almost here has heard about it
and you've probably seen it you probably
saw it on DVD we saw that his box office
was several million dollars the reality
of that film though if you talk to
Morgan is he didn't make a dime from
that film now he now has a TV contract
and a TV show and he's made making his
next film and he'd produced a film
called what would Jesus do so he's
gotten some success out of it
but the reality behind the story is that
he didn't make a dime he's now starting
to see a trickling in of some money from
the DVD sales but there's what I'll get
to in a moment a little bit more is
there's a lot of misinformation about
the possibilities in narrative and
documentary film and the success behind
them and not enough true stories and
true numbers we hear a lot of them
because we run a program called the
media arts fellowships where we give out
1 million annually to filmmakers in the
United States and Mexico as well as new
media artists and so we hear a lot of
their bright stories about what they do
not make with their productions and I
think that it's pretty safe to say that
we know artists pretty well because over
20 years we've funded over 500 artists
to the tune of about 12 million dollars
and in addition I know David and eh
pretty well because we do programs where
we take films out that we've done a lot
of them to public libraries and museums
and other nonprofits around the country
where we work within eh bien often to
curate series around a certain topic
like human rights or we just had a
series called looking at jazz that went
to several places around the country
with neh support so we also know about
reaching audiences with us with these
projects one of the things that we've
learned about with artists is that and
again I should point out we are not
about open content we don't require that
with our grants right now although it's
something we every now and then talk
about but we've learned a lot from our
artists one is that they want the
freedom to create their vision and on
top of that and very close second they
hope to make a living from what they're
doing however most of them don't and
while you would think that would lead
them to think about alternate strategies
you know Morgan Spurlock if you asked
him will you give your film away for
free and an open content system of any
end of the spectrum his aunt ro would be
no he wants to make sales of that film
and that's a reality that we have to
face with a lot of content the other and
we think that's fair enough artists
should be able to make some kind of
living
from there from their work and we also
feel that there's a myth going around
that nowadays you can just do anything
you want there's the cameras are so
cheap you can distribute it so cheaply
through YouTube and while I watch
user-generated content quote-unquote we
call them filmmakers as much as everyone
else does the reality is the quality
educational content and quality
important artistic works often still
take a lot of money to fund most of the
artists that we fund are never spending
less than two hundred thousand dollars
in their production and often they're
hovering around two million dollars for
both documentaries and fiction films
it's still expensive and while there are
new resources to get your films out
there to a public the most successful
video on River which is one of the few
places that pays people for their
user-generated content videos the most
successful one the coke mentos video I
think everyone probably seen that where
they put the Mentos in the coconut
sprays everywhere I think that's now
made maybe thirty thousand dollars that
is payback from Reverend that's the most
successful story they have so we don't
necessarily consider that a success
ourselves some other realities out there
is and it's very obvious it's an
underfunded overproduced field and
that's probably because everyone thinks
they'll be discovered and they'll become
the next Morgan Spurlock who they've
heard made a lot of money but he didn't
and the other thing we've learned a lot
about from our filmmakers is they don't
think about distribution or the
educational use of their film in
particular and if they do they don't do
it until the film's already done they
don't have the money for it and they're
at the point where they'll just take any
offer that any distributor comes to with
them to get their film out to a wider
public and they don't really think in
advance of the possibilities of their
film and alternate ways of getting it
out there and one of the reasons is
there's no real numbers out there
available that tell you this is how
little Morgan Spurlock made on his film
you go to variety calm even all you can
get is a box office report well the box
office is nothing it's a marketing
campaign for the DVD sales so that tells
you nothing about the reality of what
someone makes on their film and so
there's a real need out there for that
some other realities we need to know
about
the media artists and open content and
the possibilities are that while would
be great you know the idea of having
everything accessible our worlds and
worlds knowledge accessible free and
open to the world especially to
educational one of the places where
filmmakers do make money is in sales to
the educational marketplace often three
hundred dollars a pop for a video tape
not even a DVD and while that can seem
ridiculous it's a reality in the
marketplace that we need to think of an
address and thinking about open content
most of the filmmakers we talked to are
not only not open to alternate licensing
or the possibilities or things like
Creative Commons and other open content
movements they're not even aware they
exist as a whole the majority of our
artists that we support and then we know
know what they've read in variety and
they don't know much about these
alternate options and because no one has
given them a viable model which could
pay them a living for their work they
often are very resistant to the notion
and someone can give them that
possibility that that might work and we
started to sell some stories ourselves
that helped there and I'll talk about
those real quickly now and I want to
talk about two interventions first that
we've had and one is that in talking to
Peter Kaufman and others actually we
started thinking about and actually
talking to Karen martez who used to be
the head of POV on PBS and she's now at
the sundance documentary Institute we
started asking the question well what
would some other models be for this is
there a way that perhaps we could think
about funding media artists up front
maybe a little bit more for their work
and that can guarantee that maybe they
make something on their work and what if
you even let them possibly put it out in
the marketplace for a limited window of
time and they could profit from that
work they could sell it to whoever the
highest bidder is and hope they make
money from it whatever but it's a
stipulation of your funding it had to
revert to some other alternate licensing
scheme after that window of time perhaps
after five years it went back into the
public domain or into Creative Commons
license with attribution etc what would
the possibilities be and we've then we
found in telling an asking that question
that we're getting artists especially
established artists who realize they've
not made a dime and they're struggling
and there's no longer teaching jobs to
support their careers anymore they're
open to those ideas and so we don't have
a lot of money to play with our money
predominantly comes from the Rockefeller
Foundation Board Foundation and others
and we re grantor so we can't do a lot
but we just decided to do for our 20th
anniversary this year we decided what if
instead of hiring someone and paying the
money to make a commercial about us what
if we gave the money to artists but we
sampled this idea and what we did we put
out a call to all of our artists saying
we'll give you money up front to make
less than one minute short piece and our
only stipulation is that you have to
make it under a creative commons
sampling license and we were amazed that
we actually got a really good response
from tons of our artists we were able to
finally select five because all the
money we had to pay and they ranged from
emerging to established artists great at
first I actually had a website that i
emailed in to show everyone but and and
for time sake I'll just skip it and say
that we got some great works which we
premiered at the tribeca film festival
just a couple weeks ago they're on our
website which is renew media org so very
simple to find and they usually pop up
right on the first page as an
advertisement you can click on them we
made a deal with I spot which is under
if everyone knows I spot ey e spot com
it's an online website where you can mix
and match video they have a very simple
editor you know it's almost like an
iMovie that's you can load your times
and you can mix it with other people's
content you can mix it with Creative
Commons songs and spit it back out to
your cell phone if you want and we've
got all those works up there and we're
now encouraging the general public to
take those same works mix them mash them
up and we have a contest where the same
original five artists will decide who
wins it and we actually know what the
prize will be yet but we're hoping that
a company will give us something to give
away the second intervention which is
very simple to describe is as I
mentioned before there's a lot of false
stories but not a lot of reality so we
have contracted with Peter Kaufman
and intelligent television here through
a macarthur funded study to study the
economics of distribution with the goal
we hope will prove our theory that
people aren't making money if you look
at the amount of money going into the
productions and the amount of money
coming back to them there's a gross
disparity and perhaps when you have the
numbers in front of you we can start to
tilt the thinking of the foundation
world other funders public media funders
as well to end the filmmakers themselves
to realize wait a minute not just Morgan
but no one is making money there's four
or five people every year that might be
making some money and maybe that can
help do something different so those are
two easy interventions that we've
started though and all of those will be
available on our website so I have some
proposals that I've thought about for
the financing of open video that we need
to think about and then I'll go into our
throat intervention very quickly one is
that I hear a lot of black and white in
a lot of these rooms and I think most
people here are pretty reasonable so
they understand this but I think it's
really important to realize that the
future is not open versus paid that's
not going to ever be what the future is
it's going to be a mix of those two and
it's not going to be top down versus
bottom up there's one of the
user-generated content and is one of
these stuff that's funded by HBO and
whoever else and those two worlds are
going to coexist just like every other
technology we always settle into some
kind of medium the other is that the
commercial non-commercial split is
pretty much fiction and we need to
realize that most of the producers that
are making stuff educational use are
also hoping to make it for commercial
markets etc the other reason is very
simple but broadcast will not die there
will go be hybrid models but it's
nowhere near dead the other is it
neither his text i think it was back in
nineteen ninety the gregory omer first
proposed the idea of electricity the
idea of the movement for morality to
literacy to electricity which is
electronic enabled thought processes
business models everything around the
idea of a mix of gaming web video all
coming together for a new electronic
enabled thought and that was something
to propose back before somebody come up
with a ridiculous term of web 2.0 for
it is what we envisioned the web time
ago there's nothing new about the about
what's going on in the web this is stuff
I mean we were supposed to right now be
in virtual reality goggles talking to
each other and zooming through
cyberspace to pick out what we wanted
and we're still way behind so that's the
other thing is technology is slow and so
we've got to kind of use duct tape to
pull together the innovative projects
that we want the other thing that we
think is really important to keep in
mind and and when you're doing in
educational settings people don't talk
about we say students but I woke up one
day and realize I was reading the paper
and they take you keep on saying the
consumers keep buying that I'm the
consumer that's me as well as everyone
else and so I think we need to realize
that the consumer is king and we need to
focus on what the audience wants not
what we want them to want and so what
I'm kind of getting around all with all
of this is that we need pragmatic
solutions and that nonprofit and
education and philanthropy need to start
thinking about pushing innovation with
new ideas that are very much practical
pragmatic and can offer new solutions
for getting this content out there and
it may be combined different processes
to get to where we want with open
content at different varieties of the
spectrum so this is our last
intervention the one that hopefully will
wake the room up a little bit called the
reframe project which we have just now
officially launched with support of the
MacArthur Foundation and in partnership
with amazon com and our projects goal is
in some ways much like the Google book
project but with the rights holders
permissions and with them actually
having a chance to make money back for
their works and what we've done is we've
realized there's a lot of films stuck on
the shelf there's a lot of film and
analog formats and others that aren't
accessible and because it writes
clearance issues etc and there's a lot
of filmmakers and distributors and
archives not archives as much but
definitely distributors of content that
we want to use in the educational
setting that right now are not open to
open content models although they may be
so in the future the other thing we
realized is that when I've done at Rice
University people kept on saying
quickly well you know we have to face
the the sustainability issue and the
rights issues and then they'll move on
to some other topic because I don't want
to talk about those two because they
didn't have an answer for any of them so
we think we've built with this project
which I'll go through something that
could potentially be a sustainable
solution to get this content out there
and they could move into open content
solutions so what we've done is we have
partnered with Amazon custom flicks and
unbox to other divisions and we are
going out to archives distributors
filmmakers with a large body of content
museums libraries and we're going to be
offering to digitize their entire
libraries for free on video for free on
film at cost and when I say it costs we
have worked with the lab and this is not
a less than quality job we're working
with an established laboratory and on
average it will cost about four hundred
dollars for 90 minutes of 16 millimeter
or 35 millimeter with sound we can also
do super 8 regular 8 all kinds of
formats for that or cheaper it's about
four hundred dollars however we do it on
a deferred basis so you can start making
money back from that content sale and
start paying off the cost of that
digitization and we hope to be moving to
where film will be free as well it's a
deal that we have made with Amazon is
non-exclusive and that's a key thing to
keep understanding throughout this
entire thing so while we will help you
digitize your works and make them for
sale which I'll talk about in a second
how this is not exclusive so if you work
for example to come to us and say I want
to work with a different lab and then
put my stuff in her system will work
with you on that basis as well if you
want when we digitize your works by the
way we will give you back at the
beginning a digital copy of your work as
a DVD master and if that's not good
enough quality for you we can offer
almost any item you want a hard drive
you know what you need for itunes and
we'll give it to on a non-inclusive
basis and you can take that content and
they could available for free on an open
content system or you could make it
available for sale through itunes we
don't care we're definitely going on the
long tail model of realizing if it's in
our system we don't care where else it
exists one of the things that we are
to help people deliver it through three
methods DVD on demand and we think this
is a crucial part of the project that
makes it different than what other
people are doing every single day I
think today to more places launched that
are offering digital downloads and the
reality is that's that's great but no
one's abusing it's a very small
marketplace people still want something
they can get on to their TV and people
still want DVD at this time so we're
offering DVD on demand no inventory is
needed so you don't have to print a
thousand copy run or something like that
we're also offering digital download to
own or to rent at prices set by the
rights holder and favorable splits to
the rights holder and at variable x of
rental so for example a university could
choose to download a digital copy to
their server and show it in their
classroom and have it expire after
they've shown it once or after an entire
semester or they could give logins for
their students which could last for an
entire semester or for an entire year or
you can purchase the copy in perpetuity
we can set all of those based on what
the right holder wants to do and what
the university's want to do and again
all of these options are opt-in so if
you want to do DVD on demand but not
digital download you can opt to do that
all of them are opt-in processes and the
last thing where it says ingest
on-demand here is not the best solution
but if you've got a large body of film
content and you don't have the money for
the digitization we haven't been able to
help you raise a grant for it we can do
a project called ingest on-demand where
we put all of your metadata into the
system and working with Amazon they have
some algorithm that I can understand
that says after four people or whatever
look at it they're confident it's going
to sell enough that they'll go ahead and
ingest it and digitize it and cover all
the costs so we can do things like that
as well we are also simultaneously
because getting it up on Amazon big deal
who's going to find it we're building a
separate website the refrain website
that is an educational marketplace
focused website and if you imagine all
of the social networking that's out
there on Facebook and everything else
it'll be part of our website but geared
towards professors scholars and other
educators who want to find content
and get it out to their students and
others they can recommend things to each
other if you're a professor of film
studies in Oklahoma you could look at
what David bored well as teaching in his
class at university of madison wisconsin
order the same thing for your students
put it on your syllabus they could find
the work download it themselves
recommend it to their mom whatever they
want to do it's branded by the catalog
holders or whether it's a filmmaker or
distributor or an archive and it's very
participatory and we're using Amazon's
recommender systems there's a lot of
this project go quickly ask questions
later here's a little schematic made by
someone who thinks right to left instead
of left to right so you have to look at
it someone in reverse but the idea is
that the reframe project any Content
holder can put their analog content or
digital to in to us we return a digital
copy to them on a non-exclusive basis
they can take it out and any other
marketplace they want to we can help
them make it available for DVD on demand
digital download a rental it's a
non-exclusive multiple marketplace
option as well where we will go out and
on behalf of thousands of hours of
content we're hoping to have ten
thousand titles in this system within
one year's time and we're confident we
can do that based on conversations we've
already had with some content holders
because of that we'll be able to
negotiate that our splits for them with
just like itunes etc and then the last
thing is in this of what becomes
important to this meeting is because
it's not exclusive if people want to
make their content available on a free
basis on any kind of range of open
content if they want to make it
available for free in certain settings
and the--and others we can help them do
that through our website and then the
last thing is because this is not
something that's easy to do from the
beginning we realize we have to address
all the different problems here so we
are doing a series of convenings around
particular solutions to certain problems
such as public media such as archival
issues when you when your film can and
be digitized because it's not a shape to
be done so how do we address that our
hope is to be doing joint large grants
to Britain to bring out to archives
where we can say this is an important
body of work that needs to be preserved
to kept an analog format yet we can put
it in the system and make it sustainable
and last we will also be doing a lot of
work around rights issues which will be
a huge stumbling block for a lot of this
work and most of it will become bigger
than what we can solve but we're hoping
it can be a nexus where people can
gather to think about these issues and
try to address them and the people who
are better at it than us like public
knowledge etc can address those issues
and those are on the last thing is again
we think that this could be a
sustainable way to work towards open
content because we've built what we've
terms and coined a with profits illusion
not nonprofit not-for-profit but the
combination of the two they could allow
for both open and paid content and
potentially become a sustainable place
to have both and thank you